le cbd est l'une des molécules contenues
dans le cannabis tout comme le thc
mais contrairement à celui ci le cbd ne
procure aucun effet euphorisant
on lui prête plutôt des propriétés anti
inflammatoires
selon nicolas boulay ancien joueur des
alouettes de montréal
le cannabis violent a amélioré son
bien-être au niveau de la douleur
certainement là cette année j'ai joué à
comines est déchiré grande partie de la
saison donc l'inflation depuis octobre
la fédération de triathlon des états
unis est commandité par un producteur de
cbd
elle est ainsi devenu le premier organe
d'un sport olympique à s'afficher ainsi
l' agence mondiale antidopage a retiré
le cannabis violent des produits
interdits en janvier 2018 et a été imité
par le baseball majeur il ya quelques
semaines dans la ligue nationale de
hockey on teste les joueurs pour
détecter du cannabis mais on ne leur
impose aucune sanction
ancien attaquant du canadien de montréal
admet en avoir consommé à sa dernière
saison dans la ligue nationale il ya
deux ans la canadienne de football ne
fait pas de test de dépistage du
cannabis
les joueurs ne craignent donc pas d'être
suspendu les joueurs ont jamais eu peur
de s'afficher zaoui j'apprends de cbd
parce que nous on n'est pas assez pour
ne jamais tu es passé pour d'autres
façons et puis il y en a plusieurs qui
pensent comme moi le rugby a une
longueur d'avancé dans son approche du
cannabis violent le wolf pack de toronto
qui joue dans la super league anglaise
lancé il y a trois mois sa propre crème
à base de ces bd sur le marché
britannique devenant la première équipe
de sport professionnel à se lancer dans
cette aventure
le but est commercial bien sûr mais
l'équipe veut surtout permettre aux
joueurs d'utiliser un produit dénué de
substances illicites comme le
à kinshasa
mike cammalleri a fondé biosteel en 2008
en octobre dernier l'entreprise qui
produit des boissons et des suppléments
énergétique a été acquise à 72% par
canopy groff cette compagnie canadienne
qui oeuvrent dans l'industrie du
cannabis veut lancer une boisson à base
de cbd sous la bannière de bio style
entre temps qu'un happy financera une
étude auprès d'une centaine d'anciens
joueurs de la lnh afin d'analyser les
effets du cbd en matière de commotions
cérébrales
la psychiatre gabriella gobbi étudie les
effets du cannabis depuis 15 ans elle
vient d'ailleurs de publier les
résultats concluants d'une étude de
l'université mcgill fait sur des
rongeurs
un avis que les cas la vidéo avait un
effet analgésique était diminuée
diminuer la douleur mais faisait encore
plus ils diminuaient aussi l'anxiété qui
était présent chez les animaux qu'il y
avait une douleur chronique afin de
démontrer l'efficacité du cbd chez les
humains il faudra qu'une étude soit
faite avec une partie des patients qui
prendra du cannabis viol et une autre
partie un placebo parce que le cerveau
foncez les résultats
dc soigner dans quelques fois surtout
plus pour la douleur si on prend des
médicaments et on est convaincu que la
douleur va baisser notre serveur capable
il faudra patienter encore au moins
trois ans avant de connaître les
premiers résultats scientifiques des
effets du cbd sur les humains michel
chabot radio canada montréal